[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel elmidoro dans
le reste de l'actualité les conséquen
bien sûr de cette attaque terroriste
d'aras la France est actuellement placée
en alerte urgence attentat et ce matin
la Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
Valérie PCR annoncé un renforcement de
la sécurité dans les lycées de la région
les brigades régionales de sécurité vont
être doublé pour passer de 50 à 100
agents sur le terrain en attendant ses
recrutements Valérie pcrè a aussi
annoncé que la région allait faire appel
à la sécurité privée et à des brigades
cinnophiles pour sécuriser les abords
des lycées qui en feront la demande elle
plaide également pour en renforcement
des clôtures des portiques d'accès et
des sacs dans les établissements
l'Île-de-France a constaté une hausse de
12 % des faits de violence dans les
lycée du territoire dans l'actualité
également l'homme ficher S qui a été
arrêté vendredi aux abords justement
d'un lycée de Limet est jugé aujourd'hui
l'homme de 24 ans a été arrêté avec un
couteau vendredi dernier les policiers
l'avaient repéré aux abords du lycée con
d'orsé il a été jugé aujourd'hui en
comparition immédiate au tribunal de
Versailles pour port d'armes ce dernier
est connu des services de police pour au
moins cinq faits similaires aucun
trouble psychiatrique n'a été révélé
lors de son expertise selon no confrère
de BFM TV des photos de décapitation ont
été retrouvé dans son téléphone portable
on viendra bien sûr informé dès qu'on
aura le verdict de ce jugement en
comparution immédiate est-ce que le
château de Versailles sera bien ouvert
demain Michel oui sauf changement de
dernière minute ce sera à bien le cas
samedi aux alentours de 16h le City
Vinois avait dû être évacué et fermé
après une alerte à la bombe 10000
personnes se trouvaient sur place à ce
moment-là c'est un anonyme qui a lancé
l'alerte sur le site
mon.commissariat.fr la menace s'est
avéré être un canular de très mauvais
goût aujourd'hui tout est rentré dans
l'ordre rassurez-vous le château de
Versailles a rouvert ses portes dès hier
dimanche et puis dans ce contexte tendu
un rassemblement pour la paix a eu lieu
hier à poissi les représentants des
communautés juives musulmanes et
chrétiennes de la ville était présent
autour d'une cinquantaine de pisiaqués
objectif montré l'unité entre les
religions face à la montée des tensions
en France suite au conflit Israël au
Palestiniens on écoute la mère de
poissis Sandrine bernaau Dos Santos au
micro de Michel mon micro c'est même pas
la mairie qui a demandé au cultes de se
réunir c'est les cultes qui spontanément
ont décidé de de se réunir pour montrer
que qu'il y a des endroits où on peut
bien vivre ensemble et que voilà c'est
pas toujours compliqué quand on est
quand on appartient à des cultes
différents de pouvoir
cohabiter merci Michell et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi prês de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les Evelin
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 new